hey there everybody my name is
markiplier I was just saying hi to my
good friend here who seems to be um
exactly outside of my house I'm pretty
sure if I walk outside the house this
time I'm actually gonna see him so I
have no idea what's going on because I
mean our friend here well I don't even
remember his name like I don't even know
if the main cave did he you've neglected
yourself your home is nailed shut
decrepit and abandoned better fix it up
as soon as you can she is already closed
wait what does that even mean wait so am
I supposed to but I don't actually do
anything when I I don't actually do
anything when I turn on these lights it
just kind of is it just kind of be abitt
anyway I guess I'm nothing little I just
go out okay I kind of forgot the bow is
gonna happen yeah but anyway I don't
know if it's actually gonna do something
to me I mean this game is just kind of a
an intrigue into the psychosis of man or
I don't know something profound like
that that means something but hot don't
look in the mirror don't look out the
window what does that mean these aren't
from the journal pieces anymore these
are just random notes sitter just laying
through the house that I I don't even
know what can I you need to tidy up the
house time to welcome the guests okay so
this seems kind of important I guess
that I'm doing this now so haha I see is
giant mouth there okay but what was that
well you can't just do a noise and not
do anything to me you got to do
something
things need to make sense human beings
need some sort of order I guess in most
of the cases in this game most of these
people are not even being you're afraid
and that's why you want to fall back
asleep you need to push forward and wake
up you say so in the room with is a
noose in the Attic very strange okay uh
just a few more yeah I'm gonna just take
the time to do this because if I don't
then I'm gonna regret
okay atmospheric lighting for no reason
is the best anything else over here dog
is dead alright god he's like right
there I mean there's obvious at this
point that this isn't quite reality
right here it's not reality both in and
out of this I knew a light went out that
light went out for some reason I don't
know why usually that meant that a
monster showed up but I don't think any
monsters are here
whatever I'll push on because I'm a
baddest but I was just gonna come out
it's time time for one you're getting
slightly disturbing I don't like it but
anyways like this game is like a
profound experiment rather than an
actual game it's um an adventure into a
story that no one that the readers
doesn't quite understand and I think
that's kind of something that's to be
applauded about the maker of the game is
um have me in a constant state of
confusion throughout the entire game as
I'm playing it is really something that
I haven't encountered in a game because
even though I've been getting plenty of
evidence I've been trying to piece it
together but the threads go in so many
different directions then I'm wait this
is not a dream this is really your own
actual home again see with this like
just that note it doesn't make sense the
threads go in so many different
directions that when you start pulling
on one like the it's like a thneed from
that one movie like the Snorlax you know
well they do what did they just do stop
staring at yourself what are you doing
did he do what
what's this happened whoa what the hell
I don't have time for any of what okay
now there are suddenly symbols on the
trees out here symbols that I haven't
seen before I've never seen any of these
I don't see any hunters or anything ah
all right then the hell is going on did
I reach an ending or something yeah I'm
uh I'm a wha wha my brain is filled with
what I have no idea what's going on and
I'm utterly confused hey you uh I guess
it's just party night for my dances wait
the symbols stop wait the symbols stop
they don't there's no more symbols over
here what does that mean
uh I don't know what this means I'm so
confused because alright this is what I
was talking about how um it just starts
a it's the same setting over and over
again but it loops through this strange
story that I'm not understanding I don't
know if I'm supposed to walk away from
the symbols or what there this game
isn't really a game in that there aren't
any clues as to what I'm supposed to do
because there is no objective
immediately like I'm thrown into this
and I pretty much have made up my own
objectives throughout the entire time
that I was making her up I was playing
this game and the game maker is like
leading me through this looping story
arc that never made sense from the
beginning and still doesn't make any
sense and now I'm away from all the
symbols and I don't know if that's good
or bad or maybe I was supposed to stay
there again I don't know I'm I'm totally
I lost I don't even remember going
outside for one for one thing as soon as
I touch that clock the time flitted just
a little bit until whose dawn which I
had been in the nightmare world I had
been making it go dawn because I wanted
to wake up or something like that or I
just wanted it to be dawn again and now
I'm wandering through the woods with
Oh goal no I don't see a little girl I
don't have the insanity meter anymore I
don't have any restriction right now it
just feels like I'm walking through the
woods with no purpose unless I'm trying
to find something that's actually hidden
deep within the forest let me and I
think I found out that the game that the
horse doesn't actually loop it's just it
kind of kind of replaces things if I
don't find it then it actually was
missed but it gives me necessary things
now I've kind of gone gone so far off
the beaten path I don't even know where
I am anymore let me go back now I don't
have to miss any hunters now or well
that's what it was called in the
achievement it said the leafy things
were haunters I was looking through the
achievements trying to get an idea of
what it was with it even they were very
cryptic in their meaning er but their
message that I really don't know what
I'm doing I don't know what I'm doing
I'm just kind of rambling oh well
whatever you know uh uh as a
commentaries a lot of comments I get uh
say that I talk a lot in and that's
perfectly understandable because I do
talk a lot and I'm often found that like
I am way too good at talking to myself
because in reality here it seems like
I'm talking to you guys and in reality I
am because I'm thinking that you guys
are here in front of me but at the same
time I notice when I walk through my
house like I'm on the way to the kitchen
leak I go mmm can't wait to get some
food in my belly oh I wonder what I
should eat I don't know like I literally
wander around my apartment talking to
myself I'm up if my I bet my neighbors
just like her sitting there with their
ears up against glass listening through
their walls I'm like what's he talking
about now should we call the police I
don't know he just starts screaming
randomly and wants drugs real bad and he
was talking like quote from movies and
stuff and I don't know he sounds crazy
like if my neighbors actually knew what
I did or they wouldn't think it will
they probably think it was still crazy
but for now
I'm pretty sure I'm that one guy in my
parking public I'm pretty sure I'm that
one guy but anyway I was hoping that by
the time aha here we go I'm back at the
symbol area I was hoping by the time I
get done with my stupid story in my
video put oh my stupid dances that I'd
be back in the symbol area okay
the similary among something
like that thing that I can understand
these symbols which I have never seen
before in this game I mean some of them
I recognize but some I've never seen in
this game before they have to mean
something right like they can't just be
here for no purpose they have to be here
for perfect purpose am I wrong
I'm probably wrong but I don't notice
many do or any duplicate they'll seem to
be unique in one fashion or another I
guess this goes back there is a
duplicate with the triangle face but
this good way to hurt something
Oh what did I get
what is this what is whoa what was that
what wait wait what oh uh wha I thought
I saw a credit list at the end of the
game wait what he closes his eyes there
for a second hand his Isaac
oh no way that's the end of the game
what did I do
I don't even know what I did I didn't
even realize this was the end of the
game it can't be right that just can't
be right No what did I do
I boarded up the house what did I do
himself ah I'm so confused I don't know
what I did wrong because they never knew
I was supposed to do hmm this is more
this is one of those experimental titles
it's more of an experience as opposed to
a game itself and oh man I don't know if
the symbols are gonna stop to the writer
if they're just gonna keep going I don't
know who's going on there's a lot of
names too
I didn't think that the studio was this
big that worked on it and let me what is
that what is that Xin Jie's there's that
the m's who's this come on
im so confussed okay if I stop in front
of these trees I get these weird things
that are like and then like the list
will go and what is going on on that I'm
I'm my brain my brain is turning into
mush between this is the Stanley parable
my brain is just turning to mush here I
mean as much as you guys want to hear
about my inane ramblings
I got nothing right now like seriously
uh I don't know what I don't know what
you're from it oh no no no vember
seventh Friday once again that's
actually words I actually understand
that what does that mean does that mean
what does that mean November 9 Sunday
count these are actually turning into
words that I understand now and none of
the symbols are stopping Simon strange
November 12th Wednesday same tune Sam
bina Brian Anderson February 2nd Sunday
immemorial squish ah so confussed now
the symbols aren't on every tree anymore
in Ben Schroeder I don't know what's
happening ah Tao to the giver Steen
February 24th Monday murmur I don't know
things like notes further on the symbols
of suddenly stop does that what's going
on here don't know jack Meredith
February 26 Wednesday threads lad okay
I'm I'm not mistaken
I've reached an end
those murmur again oh so it does loop it
does loop you it does okay well that's
way late that I realized that but I
guess that's the end hang on let me try
something here whoa
ah
wait no hang on hang on is to hang on a
ticket okay what did I do wrong what did
I do wrong I don't even know if those
good or bad end
that's a confused I am well hi mmm
can I go out my front door wait oh no
I've already read these didn't I hang on
let me flip through these real quick
again and before I get to the end of
this episode in the end of this game
play and don't get me wrong I've really
thoroughly enjoyed playing this game I
haven't I've never been this like
enraptured in a story and I've been so
confused but I've been so eager to learn
what's happening but I'm kind of upset
because it hasn't told me what's
happening
like I want to learn I wanna be a
learner of things but no you're not
gonna give it to me you're not gonna
give it to me
come on man maybe I'm the invisible boy
maybe I'm the invisible boy no yeah
bicycles what am I doing wrong I didn't
make it to another dawn or if I did go
to dawn it didn't happen though was
there any other room what seems horrible
inside the house we'll stop scaring you
if you go out into the woods touch them
without fear opening your eyes don't be
afraid to look don't be afraid to see
this is not death but simply a new time
there is no death now that's a new note
from what I saw before when I turned on
lights I don't know guys don't look in
the mirror look out the window maybe
that's a clue maybe yeah cuz I was
looking in the mirror in that little
cutscene there I don't need to look in
the mirror I need to look don't look
into oneself look out because that that
thing is a representative of me - things
are representative me and I don't need
look in me I need to look out this house
is my mind I need to open my eyes maybe
that's the symbolism that I'm missing
here
yes was there whoa hi I heard footsteps
actually here consistent noises
everybody hold on for a second
hello hmm
ah saggy yeah maybe I just got the bad
end we didn't want the other notes say
that she was in the house did I see
something on the right there did I see
something is there something there damn
it
otherwise ah the mysteries the mysteries
if you guys got any advice you start
shouting it out just start spamming the
comments as hard as you can like as
you're watching right now if you're
watching if you got to this point start
spamming wait what whoa everybody hold
on what I just heard something yeah the
guests almost never killed they only
bring a bit me hurry new that I've seen
that before
I heard something I know I did can't
tell me I didn't care the mystery it's
it's an F darn mystery I don't know what
is going on and the weirdest thing is
you need to tidy up the house time to
welcome the guests yeah I'm getting to
it breath get into it breath what is it
what is it all mean what is it all mean
what does it mean beginning you think of
a layout of these houses aren't random
at least not in this world well seems to
have some sort of purpose gotta gotta
yada
ah is there anything I missed
come out it's time I'm trying man wait
no there's a week
what's that below hello there oh they
wait that's outside how do we get
outside I want to come out it is time
coming
trying to wake me up I'm probably in a
coma if this just goes on the coma trope
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be very you're
afraid and that's why you want to fall
back sleep you need to push forward and
wake up wake up that's what I need to do
I need to wake up I'm gonna wake up some
day I'm gonna wake up right now I'm
gonna wake up this is not a dream this
is really your own actual home I'm
hearing you listening to you but what do
I do
I want to do it want to follow your
orders I want to do it one turned on
every light in the house you've
neglected yourself your home is nailed
shut decrepit and abandoned better fix
it up as soon as you can see is already
closed it's at her wait a minute I do
see my insanity line it is there wait
it's only I can always see it out here
look my insanity light appeared right
there I haven't got much left
okay I've opened every single every
single one of these is there one down
below in the gap between those two
basement floors oh yeah there is there's
there's one I got I've liked that one
why isn't that one lit yeah I'm gonna
get this I don't know what to do though
ah
who's there I heard that can't tell me I
didn't I'm not even creeped out by the
noise I want to hear him damn it wasn't
who's there
no kidding ah I don't know what to do
maybe I can't maybe I did something
wrong in the gameplay maybe I'm just
doomed to not be able to know the
mystery maybe not it is the end of the
game I don't know but I got a bad
feeling that it's not cuz this [ __ ]
right here I don't know all right guys I
think that's it I've done everything I
could possibly think of I've tried
everything I don't know what's going on
I'm literally at a loss but if that's
the ending I'm slightly disappointed but
I'm leaving this game just as confused
as I went into it apparently so if you
guys have something that you think that
I can do to actually fix something or
cuz I feel like I'm missing out on
something
I am definitely missing out on something
but I don't know what to do anymore it
just ends the game before I really don't
know so let me know in the comments if
there is something I can do I'll do one
more part but otherwise this is the end
I guess just as confused as when I
started so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
holidays
and then so wha
John said look all the blocks
these babies and use the sleep room
bud
murder No
you